alors tout au cours de l'émission nous
aurons deux économistes sur d'autres
plateaux avec nous pour bien comprendre
ce qui se passe j'ai mis gens qui est
vice président et économiste en chef
stratège chez desjardins bonsoir et
clément gignac ancien économiste en chef
de la banque nationale qui était
ministre au québec qui est sénateur
maintenant bonsoir clément gignac merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous je commence
avec vos dirigeants vous prévoyez vous
avez annoncé ça ce matin dans une note
économique une récession en 2023 au
canada seulement je pense que jusqu'à
présent l'hypothèse qu'on allait
peut-être pouvoir accomplir un
atterrissage en douceur force est de
constater que avec la persistance des
pressions inflationnistes avec le début
d'un potentiel enracinement des
anticipations dans les attentes des
ménages dans les attentes des
entreprises et avec les banques
centrales qui n'ont d'autre choix que
d'être très agressive très résolus à
pour combattre cette inflation la la la
sensibilité à la au taux d'intérêt qu'on
a ici au canada et en années qu'on est
parmi les plus endettés au monde ça fait
en sorte que ça sera très difficile
d'éviter une récession mais on pense
quand même que ça viendrait ce sont les
gens en eux mêmes les deux premiers prix
mais cela vous avez évalué que pour les
deux premiers trimestres au canada les
trimestre serait négatif
aux états unis on n'est pas encore dans
ce scénario là mais on voit bien que le
trimestre numéro 1 de 2003 recule de 0.5
et les trimestres numéro de 0,8 pour
cent donc deux trimestres négatifs dans
la première moitié de l'année vous êtes
une légère seulement contraction
contrairement à ce qu'on a vécu en
pandémie contrairement à ce qu'on a vu
en 2008 2009 c'est une ressource enquis
de courte durée et de faible ampleur
mais quand même plusieurs éléments
porteurs dans ce succès pour ce qu' il
ya encore beaucoup de gens qui s'attend
à ce que ce soit une relative douceur à
cause du marché du travail qui est très
serré à cause également de l' épargne
accumulée par les ménages donc ces
facteurs là sont porteurs
mais il reste quand même on va subir
d'après nous une contraction êtes vous
du même avis que les mains gignac ouais
j'suis d'accord
je pense comme économiste c'est de
croire qu'on va pouvoir combattre cette
inflation puis retourner vers une cible
de 2 % s'en passer à voir le passage par
une récession momentum pour assurer les
gens des récessions il y en ait
différentes types jimmy l'évoquer en
option était très profond mais très
courtes comme celle de la pandémie yen
inquiète donc profonde et longue comment
80 81 2 quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
d'ailleurs que nous messieurs desjardins
une inflation pas au-delà de 10% donc il
y en a de toutes les natures toutes les
sortes eu environ deux douzaines de
récession depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale mais celle-ci que c'est un bien
selon moi ça sera une récession à typer
je m'explique c'est à dire que les
économies seront raisons qui auraient un
repli du pib mais ça sera pas le serment
compagnie par une poussée du taux de
chômage parce que vous l'avez évoqué je
pense dans l'intervention patrick roy
pas très souvent oui à savoir que quand
même au delà de 250 mille poisse avec un
au québec ou de la 2 millions canada
donc oui il y aurait des licenciements
dans certains secteurs mais la
possibilité pour des gens de se
retrouver un emploi à céret plus demain
dans un autre secteur moyen de même
certaines formations donc ça serait pas
compagnie par une poussée importante du
taux de chômage contrairement aux
récessions précédentes donc expliquer ce
que l'on parle de récession au canada en
2023 est ce qu'au québec aussi on est en
récession je pense que le québec va au
subir un ralentissement très important
on devrait voir également les pressions
sur le marché du travail
s'amenuiser est-ce que ça va être une
récession s'avère difficile à dire mais
il reste qu'on est la deuxième économie
en importance au canada si le canada est
en récession c'est certain que ça va
nous affecter est ce qu on sait aussi
que pour lui cette poussée de
l'immobilier qu'on ait eu à toronto
vancouver donc et moins de déséquilibre
dans le secteur d'habitation que ce
qu'on a vu dans le reste du canada et en
plus faut penser que le gouvernement du
québec les finances publiques sont en
sont très saines et le gouvernement du
québec est assez agressif loupé avec les
élections qui s'en viennent promet qu'on
voit si t'es un autre simulation de la
part du gouvernement du québec au plan
budgétaire donc tout ça pour faire en
sorte que supprimant plus 50 50 les
résolutions mais on s'entend pour
s'éclairer sont moins élevés au québec
que dans le jeu ce cadeau aux états unis
est ce que le pic de l'inflation et
atteint parce que fondamentalement c'est
ça on a un niveau d'inflation qui est
élevée en une banque centrale qui est
agressive qui doivent mans très
rapidement les tos a ralenti l'économie
manta clément gignac est ce que le pic
est atteint et finalement on voit la
lumière au bout du tunnel une descente
de l'inflation la bonne nouvelle gérard
ce que je pense que le pic de
l'inflation totale qui inclut le prix de
l'essence et demain est atteint par
contre la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
l'inflation sous jacente j'enlève
exemple les éléments sujet enlève
l'énergie ce n'est pas clair qu'on a
atteint le sommet son expulsion prend
l'inflation fondamentales qu'ont
excluent certains composants volatils on
voit une accélération que s'est
poursuivie moderni et l'homme maintenant
plus ont une accélération des salaires
qui rend plus compliquée la lutte contre
l'inflation de la part des banques
centrales mais quand même on voit dans
l'économie mondiale par exemple d'autres
tellement parlé des chaînes
d'approvisionnement jimmy jean au cours
des derniers mois puis des dernières
années on a l'impression que ça se règle
tranquillement cette entrée on est en
train de remettre de l'huile dans
l'engrenage et que les coûts de
transport sont faits en train de baisser
également est-ce que ça va atténuer
l'inflation commence à reprendre
avant que ça se transmettent dans l'est
dans les biens de consommation
il faut contrer plusieurs mois plusieurs
trimestres et effectivement entre temps
il ya encore des risques sont très
importants monsieur gignac l'a mentionné
oui les prix de l'énergie qui contribue
à cette atteinte du sommet de
l'inflation mais on sait avec le
contexte géopolitique très volatile ça
peut très facilement repartir en hausse
donc lire ce que je pense que les
pressions les risques à la hausse
l'inflation demeure très important où
les risques finalement ça se modère pas
aussi rapidement qu'on l'espère et donc
ça oblige la banque du canada à
continuer d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur
de la hausse des taux d'intérêt et
aimant donc on pourrait passer de 8% de
taux d'inflation à 5 6 % assez
facilement si le prix du pétrole
continue à diminuer mais passer de 5% à
2% ça va prendre du temps surtout avec
une accélération des salaires et il ya
des changements structurels aussi sans
parler de la lutte aux changements
climatiques l'empreinte carbone la taxe
carbone les sécheresses qu'on peut voir
du côté de convois dans différents pays
donc tout sauf céder quand même une
pression
des facteurs structurels qui vont faire
un centre difficile de rendre une
impression 2% et si les banques
centrales veulent aller rapidement si le
risque de la récession king les
investissements des entreprises vont
ralentir est ce que la consommation qui
est quand même importante dans
l'économie ralentit et va ralentir aussi
en ce moment la consommation on n'est
pas en récession donc clairement
l'économie va bien on va avoir des
chiffres la semaine prochaine sur le pib
on se pense que ça sorte acat ennemis
pour ça donc on est en quart le deuxième
trimestre de 2022 doit on encore à la
mi-année de 2022 on est encore bonne
posture par contre quand on regarde les
indices de confiance des ménages c'est à
la baisse aux etats unis on a touché un
creux record
au canada on voit la même tendance qu'on
voyait avant la récession de 2008-2009
d'un indice de confiance canadiens de
plus en plus quand j'ai regardé trois
quatre enquêtes autant aux états unis et
au canada c'est à environ 60 à 80 % des
ménages qui indique est en train de
réduire leurs dépenses non essentielles
aussi une tendance inquiétante c'est
qu'on voit de plus en plus de gens
recourent et au crédit au canada c'est
25% recourir au crédit pour acheter une
maison ou un chalet mais pour faire face
à la hausse du coût de la vie
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit
[Musique]